I'm just thinking about how spooky it's
getting in the world because it's
Halloween time you know it's Halloween
man Halloween I mean I so love do you
remember hallouwe remember the remember
how much fun you remember remember how
much fun you had remember how much fun
you had Halloween what are you gonna be
what are you gonna be for like a couple
of weeks when you were in like
elementary school middle school what are
you gonna be what are you gonna be I'm
gonna be a princess I'm gonna be a coal
miner I'm gonna be a firefighter that
was always a big one I'm gonna be a
firefighter
you know and it was just like a and and
the costume used to be way more normal
weight like Oh Daniel is a bat oh that's
good job Daniel you know a Lawrence is
um he's a coal miner in a wheelchair oh
good job Lawrence Celina is pregnant
Oh oh that's interesting but way to go
Celina you know you just you see that
little girl she'd come to the door she
you know she does that's her idea of a
what of creativity she's seven years old
she got a pillow in her you know and
lipstick on you're like okay she's you
know maybe seeing a little too much at
the house you know but that was that was
that was then that was that was
Halloween dude and then I remember you
would get the candy and I always liked
them Snickers them baby Snickers you
know out here and and and Los Angeles
they give all you know the costumes are
you know out here it's not even uh it's
not even know you know it's like Jackson
is a hashtag
Lorenzo well he refuses to dress up this
year because he believes that Halloween
is you know it's
it's not fair to ghosts like actual
ghosts aren't getting the credit they
deserve yeah well [ __ ] that bruh
Halloween is a great opportunity to get
an empty bag or anything empty did I
remember one time running around our
neighborhood with a plant pot because it
just seemed like the biggest thing
around
fill it up I didn't care what you put in
it dude I remember one got us poured
half of a beer out in the mine I'm like
here dude I love getting them little
Snickers and I love putting on my
costume
you look I found these sounds remember
listen to these Halloween masks sounds
okay these were sounds that your masks
made maybe when you put the mask on
alright here we go
[Applause]
remember that okay now what about this
one listen to this one that now if you
had some money that second when you had
a little bit of money because they had
that hard that plastic it it was like
getting back in you in your mother's
womb just once you got whatever that and
then that thing was always like a wolf
or like a you know a donkey head or uh
you know it could be anything it would
be but it was something like severe like
a big lizard head if you got into that
thing you weren't that was it for the
night
I didn't like those things because I
always felt trapped you know I remember
one time being in a costume and I
couldn't get that thing off man and I
could see out of the eyes and I could
see the world like so clearly but no one
could hear me because the plastic was
too thick so I'll quit talking to people
and it was sweaty and it was scary
because I couldn't like my peripheral
vision was gone so I couldn't see around
me that good and I could just see and I
was just like I was watching the world
happen a little bit more and I thought
for a second when I honestly I thought
that was
I wonder if this is what it feels like
to have like autism or Down syndrome you
know like you're in there and you can
see like it all seems really really
clear but you're like sweating and and
uh and you and you can't and people
can't hear you or you can't like
communicate as well because you know you
got on these you know you got so much
extra on you you know I mean that
getting into that one this is another
one this is one more sound here we go
that's kind of similar similar one but
yeah Halloween oh man Halloween and you
were run by you have that candy dude I
remember this I wanted candy so bad I
remember grabbing like my wiener and
just squeezing it that's how Brandi and
I wanted that snicker man every time I
wanted that snicker that's exactly give
me this or did they have the snicker no
somebody had a sucker what is dad [ __ ]
I'll get that at the bank
I'll get that at a dang chat at a bank
I'll get that at a Whitney bank that's
what they used to have in Louisiana that
Whitney Bank
it's crazy man there was so much fun
dude and I remember my mom had that
station wagon and the station wagon do
you could hide in the old school now
they got these little Subaru Legacy you
know we had that we had the station
wagon this thing was that war war to
hitter I'm saying if you got far enough
into the back you could hear soldiers
fighting that [ __ ] the fifth row you
know the they had the backseat then they
had this big extra-long area that was
straight-up Dunkirk back there people
were losing their lives back there and
my momma they had the station wagon had
an arm it had a thing it dropped down
you know because this is when I was
this is when I was probably let me think
five okay or six and they had that that
the station wagon had a back thing it
was a like a tailgate it was a tailgate
and we just drive down it was heavy bruh
if it came down you you didn't put it
back up till maybe spring time or until
a different time of year you know it was
that thing was heavy and we would all
get on there and hang we would all get
up we'd stand on there and be all
dressed up in our costumes you know
everybody would be keyed up and just you
know somebody would be a um somebody
would just be like I'm a I'm a like a
bloody ghost and they would just you
know have blood all over him and maybe
have a bed she kind of tied around them
it actually just looked like a Greek
person that had been you know in a
domestic dispute you know you'd have
some horrible [ __ ] costumes you know
now it's a little bit more like the
parents dress the kids I feel like when
I when I was young you drew dude you
just you know I remember you put a
little bit of dirt on you like I'm on my
um piece of sod you know you put a
little bit of suck you know maybe some
grass in your hair but it was fun man
and we'd all get on the back of that we
get on the back of mom station wagon and
she'd let us stand on the tailgate she
let us stand on the tailgate cuz I lived
in America in the 90s and you could
stand on the tailgate and you could hold
on at the top of the station wagon and
mom would drive around the rich people's
neighborhood and I'd be on the back out
ad man just waiting you see a house
where it looked like they had somebody
sitting out front like a senior citizen
or something you know in a rocking chair
and they were all dressed up and they
you know they had like us maybe some
decorations like oh these mother has got
that snicker these the people that got
the snicker because when I was young
that's all you wanted man some people
during Halloween they were giving out
the little they used to have these black
these candies they were like it was just
a it was kind of
somebody at they were orange-and-black
the it was just wrapped up and it was
barely wrapped up some of the candy was
kind of leaking out the back end you
know some of the candy had a little bit
of side boob kind of you know a little
brown kind of side boob popping out it
uh the wrapping you know these little
candies they came in little wrappers
little you know little blankets little
duffel bags for candies were you know
wrappers wrappers and and they would
give you these into his Chewie it was
chunk
you didn't even it was it was unn it was
the unknown candy it was like the tomb
of the unknown diabetes it was just a
chunk of you were like oh is this
chocolate is it caramel and then is it
Apple and you would just eat it and by
the time you even kind of maybe had an
idea what it was it was gone and you had
no idea what it was and it was actually
absolutely just nothing just garbage
straight up just that I mean it was I
mean it could have been a polio vaccine
I have no clue what it was I mean it
could have been I just remember it
gotcha sugar up and got you amped up to
go another couple blocks you know and I
remember a couple of them if you had two
or three too orange ones in a row you
couldn't turn your neck for a little bit
that [ __ ] would get my neck all tight
make my veins really start you know make
my veins kind of dance together and kind
of get to know each other a little bit
maybe even doing you know make it make
you feel like your neck didn't want it
your neck would get tight if I had too
many of them little because they were
just unknown candies they didn't have a
name to him they were cheap and they
just it was just enough to get you to
that next house and see if they had a
little thing of Smarties bra rich people
always had Smarties or you know it loved
Snickers know you on Halloween bruh
dude I would train all month in October
at the house stretching you know
fighting my getting beat up by my
brother you know pissing my mom off let
her hit me with that leather because I
was gonna be ready for October 31st when
Daddy little daddy hit the night time
but I was about
Rokk way silo Joe hit the night time
going looking for that snicker and they
call me and they see me they see me and
they know I'm hunting that sénèque ax
and I'd be out there and we'd be on the
back of moms and I've told this story
yeah I probably told her last how I mean
I'll be on the back we'd all be lined up
on the back of us one of us you know
somebody's just easy easy easy costumes
somebody's a turtle you know little
Ronald's a turtle you know little fan
you know he's a um he's a goat and he
got some real goat hair his dad put real
honey and goat hair on his back to make
him look out I'll tent it and he's a
real little goat boy and they put little
fake horns on his head you know and they
squeezed him maybe into a um they might
have squeezed him into a mask I don't
even know they might have squeezed him
in one of those tight hitters and little
fan yells all keyed up and maybe they
even maybe his dad he had a little bit
extra time off of work you're in October
and he put real wood on the bottom of
his shoes and he any any and he nailed
it into the bottom of his shoes er or
super glued it onto the bottom and
painted it black so now little Daniel
got real hoofs and he you know maybe
he's out there in the up on mom you know
children's underwears or you know or
even sometimes in Halloween you put on a
baby diaper you put a diaper on your
body you know in case she wanted a piss
or something because you wouldn't you
know we went hard at Halloween there was
it and we was in we were on enemy
territory we're out there
trick-or-treating by the ridge
do you trick-or-treat in my neighborhood
do you get probably you get a rash for
sure bedbugs you get probably I mean say
they have registered a lot of registered
sex offenders boss so you know none of
these freelance boys I'm talking people
in the Union you know them real hitters
so you wouldn't really you know a lot of
people are bonds then you have calendars
you stop by a dressed-up you know they
might think you a real animal if you
come by little fan Yule rolls up as a
goat brother they might [ __ ] grill
that boy up
you know we having a little bit of we
having some rack of Fanueil back here
next weekend we having a barbecue but
yeah man we would go and Daniel would
have heat up maybe real goat hair on him
you know his dad would put honey on the
back of his legs and honey on his back
and then they had real goats so they
could get real hair off these goats
because that's free if you have goats
that hair is yours if they're cool with
it and you put it on and then he like
damn that boy looks [ __ ] he's a real
swaggy piece out here and we'd all be on
the back of the and we'd have those
diapers on because we weren't going back
home you know I'm saying if you if the
diaper was because if you wanted to
urinate her or you know or make Duty and
you could do it right there and still
trick-or-treat because this was our this
was our Vietnam October 31st it was us
against the world it was us against
these candy makers and these people
would have had front doors and these
people that had jack-o'-lanterns and it
was us and we was going to get ours we
were going to get them but then baby
snicker
and man it was epic and we'd all be on
the back of that [ __ ] on the back of
mom's car with that with that ah with
the tailgate down and she's rolling bro
she's cruising because she's pissed
because my mother was always pissed
think about a time when my mother has
been alive she was pissed then I promise
you and we're on the back and mom would
roll up by the yard and we would run and
jump off that tailgate into the yard as
that car was going just like I could
right out the back of a c-130 man shout
out to all of our servicemen and women
just just right out in the yard and
tumble roll into the yard lose half your
[ __ ] candy in the roll what whatever
onward onward hold the line forward I
would roll out on the ground you know
your brother your anything your sister
would come off at the last minute she
only two years old and
[ __ ] in that that mom car still
rolling just coming to a stop and my
sister just fall off that bit she
couldn't even jump her legs didn't have
that jump ability in him yet they was
just you know just them [ __ ] little
pushers she would just kind of push
herself and then just fall and she fall
right off the tailgate anything
whoever's yard it was some rich person's
yard and then it was just every step you
could get through the dark grass to get
up to that front door and you would just
ring that damn Bell you would knock dude
I would ring and then knock and if they
weren't there within half of a second I
would ring again and you would fight
over who got to say trick-or-treat
remember that cut rolling up close to
the door eat of it you'd have a six
minute fist fight over who gets to say
trick-or-treat and then you get there
and you buy and then they open it up and
sometimes inside you see people having
fun families you know maybe they're
watching TV or tickling each other maybe
the dad if he's rich he might be
throwing a piece of popcorn up in there
catching in his mouth you know maybe the
kid you see he got a nice pair of click
you know extra shoes or cleats by the
door whatever they got calendars you
know legitimate calendars from the
siddhis from the actual year it was on
the wall and then and the mom is right
there and she got the big bowl and she's
dressed up like a little cat or like a
uh you know a female lemur or
something's kind of sexy you know like a
little deer and they she got that bowl
and man you hope that snicker was in
there
god I loved Halloween and then it was on
to the next one and you make the street
and then you there weren't as many you
know you didn't see as many porch lights
on you be like alright let's get back on
the car let's get back on mom's tailgate
go mom and mom's complaint is everybody
your back a yelling bra half your candy
only no you point your getting your
brother to look at something stealing
after his [ __ ] you got all the candy
bags tied around your sister's neck
she's at this point she's just a sugar
mule
she's just mewling sweets all right yes
you know she's 2 years old building up
thighs she you know by that by the end
of Halloween not by November 1st she got
thighs looked like a damn quarter horse
look like a UH pony that was raised in
quicksand and it's still alive she got
them big strong thighs and she just got
9 bags of candy tied around her and she
just mule and sugar and you guys back on
the tailgate again you're going and you
see another person's yard and we'd run
and we jump off and I never forget what
happened man little Fanueil jumped off
in some people every now and then some
some real [ __ ] rue has to have a
hydrant in the front of their yard and
you know what's great about them they
don't put lights around the hydrant they
don't put any it's just a hydrant in the
front of a yard and this person had
painted their hydrant brown so it would
match their house what a real Albert
[ __ ] Stein so we all running off we jump
into the yard 1 2 3 just parachuting off
the back of mom's tailgate and little
Daniel
little Daniel a little goat boy you know
he's all shook up he's hopped up he's
had made me about [ __ ] 65 rolls of
Smarties and 15 of those you know
unidentifiable brown and black candies
he got so money he and those things you
couldn't even get him it would just get
stuck in your teeth remember that
remember those Canton that's all they
were those things is the orange and
black ones they just get all it was was
something that kind of tasted like
coffee and we get stuck in your teeth
come on but a little Daniel Bryan jumped
off and in the dark you thought it was
yard because we'd all hit yard and
[ __ ] just just landed right into that
a fire hydrant just I just imagine
flying through the air Halloween on your
brain 65 rolls of Smarties in your
system hopped up I won't be able to
close your eyes for a month you got so
much glucose rolling through you you got
real honey hooked goat hair on your back
your daddy made you [ __ ] wooden
hooves you got pine who's nailed it into
the bottom of your Reeboks and you got
on a diaper full of urine and possibly
number two pens are now fired up you
were and you got a [ __ ] damn goat
mask on your face and out of nowhere
just out of the pitch-black a fire
hydrant you jump off of a tailgate in
enough pure darkness and you hit a fire
hydrant hmm and then boy was never the
same never the same so but that's
Halloween man god I love it and I miss
it and I'm happy to be here man crazy
but different back in the day people you
could dress up as an apple you know an
Indian we have way they had a black kid
came our door as an indentured servant
like whatever people didn't care people
wasn't like oh this means this this mean
whatever this a kid they want to dress
up let them dress up you know I you know
I I people know I've been peppermint
pattie for and I'll get a you know a
cotton you know some cotton body cover
and stuff and you know shirts and that
and pants and I'll put little
peppermints all over them and people are
like who are you and I'm like I'm
peppermint Pat and they're like who is
that
and I'm like who it's no one it's
peppermint pat you know I'm saying
I'm that breath you know I'm that bit
I'm that I'm that sugary little for
I'm not sugary fresh and I'll put you
know my finger put to you know I brush
my hands along your along your cheeks
and make your breath smell nice
peppermint Pat not a real person but in
my mind it was real remember Halloween
was also a chance I remember it was a
chance to go door-to-door in your
neighborhood and see what the [ __ ] was
going on remember that you get to some
people's house you like Dan they don't
have any furniture
I remember we open one one person open
the door is just a garage their whole
house was just a garage like what are
y'all y'all sleeping in that Ford
Explorer the hell is going on but you
kind of got to see what was going on in
different people's lives man it was
interesting it was really really
interesting but happy early Halloween
I'm excited you know I get excited for
the holidays and I get excited you know
I love the holidays you know I love
things that bring people together and I
think that the holidays is one of those
things and and I think we all need it I
think we all need it good evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better what if you
watch a video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one watch this one watch
this one watch this one